carrusel de las artes
[Música]
hasta el día olivares
buenas noches toulouse voz oa tu luz tu
corazón
[Música]
siempre contracorriente
sólo se deja
[Música]
cuando se va a la gente y entonces se
hace y
se suelta el pelo
tenemos la suerte de estar con jorge
drexler aquí en el festival río loco de
toulouse somos testigos de esa conexión
con su público francés francés e
internacional muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros jorge hola qué tal es un
gusto para mí esta es mi primera vez en
toulouse de hecho en francia tú con muy
poco por razones que todavía no bueno yo
lo que creo que trabajamos tanto del
otro lado del atlántico en latinoamérica
este que a veces no se ha quedado poco
tiempo hace muchos años que no venía
francia justamente esa es una de las
preguntas he leído en la prensa francés
francesa que estás demasiado ausente o
no suficientemente presente en los
escenarios franceses eso se explica por
qué razón porque la conexión está con el
público francés
yo creo que circunstancial es decir ha
crecido mucho mucho nuestro trabajo en
latinoamérica inglés brasil incluido en
los últimos años en españa y vamos de a
poquito nos gusta hacer las cosas
bien con un fundamento a mí no me gusta
venir y luego luego no poder tener
continuidad entonces yo creo que ahora a
partir de esta visita vamos a hacer
todos un esfuerzo muy grande por tener
continuidad en francia me interesa mucho
[Música]
lo que dejó por escrito no está tallado
en granito yo apenas suelto en el viento
presentimientos pido lo que necesito
quinta de tiempo quinta de tiempo
[Música]
estamos aquí para hablar también de tu
obra y más precisamente de lo que te
trajo aquí a francia y es tu último
álbum que se llama tinta y tiempo que es
para ti la tinta y que es para ti el
tiempo la tinta y el tiempo junto con la
hoja en blanco son los tres ingredientes
para la escritura
quizás el más importante es el tiempo de
los tres para mí no escribir es un acto
de fe y un acto de paciencia es uno se
enfrenta a la hoja en blanco y es una
batalla que pierde casi todas las veces
de hecho la portada del disco es una
hoja en blanco y las pocas veces que uno
gana la batalla contra la hoja en blanco
son las que las que mostramos luego las
diez canciones del disco por ejemplo y
en la pandemia particularmente fue muy
difícil escribir para mí fue un período
de mucho aislamiento como para todos y a
mí me costó mucho escribir el
aislamiento entonces
me repetía a mí todo el tiempo y de ahí
viene esa canción tranquilo tinta y
tiempo como que las cosas lo que tenga
que ser escrito será escrito y que
quisiste poner en ese álbum además de la
página en blanco la tinta y el tiempo
hay algo más lo que quise poner en el
álbum este es un reflejo indirecto de la
pandemia no quería escribir sobre la
pandemia empecé escribiendo mucho sobre
la pandemia la soledad las mascarillas
el miedo en la distancia las pantallas
pero después dije cuando esto termine
que ya está terminando por suerte
aparentemente ojalá
está empezando a terminar cuando éste
termine yo no quiero llevarme a los
escenarios estos recuerdos quiero hablar
de lo que aprendimos a revalorizar
durante la pandemia de esas cosas que
eran muy importantes sin que supiéramos
que eran muy importantes la presencia de
otra persona el amor la conexión el
contacto físico
la demostración del amor es un disco
donde el amor tiene un rol muy central
en el disco desde el comienzo desde la
canción el plan maestro donde se
describe la invención del amor por la
naturaleza hace 1.600 millones de años
cuando por primera vez dos células que
hasta ese momento se dividían cada uno
por su lado deciden juntarse
de libros
es algo me está el tema la canción
tocarte que significa tocar en ese
contexto si cuentas bueno tocar el
contacto tocarte el acto de tocar otra
persona era realmente una de las cosas
que más
que se volvieron más peligrosas e
inclusive que echábamos en falta la
canción dice jugarte la vida buscarme la
ruina nos jugarme la vida es que
realmente en ese momento cuando
escribimos la canción una de las
personas que la escribió y acababa de
venir de encontrarse con su novia que no
se veían hace tres meses y no pudieron
tocarse porque estaban todavía estaban
cada uno tenía personas sensibles en su
casa que no quería exponer entonces
estar frente a un ser querido y no poder
tocarlo es uno de los de los dolores más
profundos que puede tener una persona
todos los abuelos que queríamos abrazar
no podíamos los hijos mi hijo llegó a
españa cuando yo estaba enfermo en marzo
y yo no podía tocarlo a él es como
fue fueron meses de cosas muy raras y
tocarte habla de eso y como no hablar de
la referencia que eres para américa
latina la referencia en función de tus
textos de tu música de tu presencia de
tu notoriedad de lo que quieres contar
de tu
digamos tu caminos hasta después de la
comida del cob it como contabas muchas
referencias e incluso que te llevaron a
colaborar con otros artistas que también
son referencias habló por ejemplo de
joaquín sabina de cerrar de mercedes
sosa- de chaquira tanganas más
recientemente tienes alguna colaboración
que ha sido insólita o la más insólita
de tu carrera algo que te venga así pues
mira de las cosas más insólitas que hice
fue la colaboración con ce tangana con
pucho porque los dos tenemos estilos muy
diferentes pero nos admiramos mutuamente
y yo siempre digo que a mí me interesa
mucho más trabajar con personas que son
diferentes de mí
porque yo ya llevo 30 años haciendo esto
y me aburro de mí
todas las personas que conozco que
tienen un poco de curiosidad les gusta
probar cosas nuevas entonces esa fue una
colaboración realmente insólita que me
llevó a escribir de manera diferente
tocarte es la canción que escribimos con
él precisamente en esa canción también
aparece mi hijo de 24 años que ahora
está de gira con c tangana y víctor
martínez el director musical de tángana
que son también alianzas que yo nunca
había tenido musicalmente fueron muy
especiales para mí en ese disco porque
también tiene una estética relacionada
con la nueva música urbana con el funky
brasileño con la música más
contemporánea con un minimalismo muy
actual muy moderno que a mí me gustó
mucho también esto no es más que otros
en el que te has culo con un traje
alquilado
ni si quiera me han dominado cuando pasó
a su lado qué le ha pasado antes
venían a verte ahora no puede tener arte
antes estabas al dente pisaba es mucho
más fuerte
antes venían a verte ahora no puede
venir verte entonces estarás al dente y
sabes mucho más fuerte
el hecho también que ahora viva vivas en
europa en españa
puede ser también una de las razones por
las cuales colaboras con españoles por
ejemplo queda alguna conexión musical
con américa latina
bueno
yo estoy conectado y eternamente con
américa latina' de hecho estoy más
conectado con américa latina desde que
vivo en españa porque a través de mi
carrera en españa el gran gran regalo
que me ha hecho la música en mi vida es
iberoamérica es la américa ibérica digo
iberoamérica porque incluye también
brasil no sea brasil todo latinoamérica
portugal y españa- para mí son mi
territorio natural me habló bien
portugués y me muevo muy cómodo en todo
en todo ese territorio de tocado en
todos los países iberoamericanos en los
últimos cinco años menos en honduras que
me quedan purina más el día le irá
pudiendo
poco a poco al frío
creo que he visto una luz
al otro lado del río quería hablar de
los 30 años recorridos desde tu primer
álbum los 30 años recorridos hay una
diferencia entre el jorge drexler de
hace 30 años y el de ahora es el mismo
hombre es el mismo artista yo creo que
soy el mismo hombre con un poco de pelo
más blanco y el cuerpo un poco más
cansado y la vista sobre todo me cuesta
leer de cerca yo te veo leer en tu en tu
papel y digo que envidia no es que
sugieres esto yo que tengo unos años más
ya me cuesta me cuesta
entonces este no sé pero sigo haciendo
música por las mismas razones que hacía
antes y son las razones que me gustan
hacer música para conocer otras personas
hacer música para conocerme a mí mismo
hacer música para hacer canciones para
ampliar el género canción estudiando la
parte de los textos con mucho cuidado la
parte de la música con mucho cuidado la
parte del sonido y la producción con
mucho cuidado intentar hacer de la
canción
una disciplina estrictamente artística
es decir tener la canción como mi género
artístico es un género que respeto
muchísimo que existe con el ser humano
desde
desde que somos una especie que cantamos
quizás cantemos antes de que hayamos
comenzado a hablar con palabras los
primeros lenguajes aparentemente eran
lenguajes muy cantados entonces yo me
siento heredero de esa tradición de
personas que juntan texto con música y
ahora que estamos en francia y
hablábamos de tus colaboraciones
internacionales hay algún francés o
alguna francesa con quien quisieras tú
colaborar o tener una conexión digamos
artística y musical
muchos con muchos hubiera dicho andy
salvador pero ya no pero ya no está más
pero
esto me encanta por decir algo no es
toma he escuchado mucho arthur h también
hace mucho tiempo pero hace mucho que no
lo vuelvo a escuchar este y henán tengo
comunicación con ella con keren ann y
voy conociendo de a pocos artistas
increíbles la que sólo finos
[Música]
y escribir en francés una canción ha
intentado
dejaba de pensar igual tengo alguna
frase en francés pero a él pero no me
acuerdo
tengo alguna frase suelta no escrito
nada en francés aún la pregunta que me
hago es
trajiste tu mate a francia no no traigo
el mate no no no no voy a jugar hacía
demasiado calor estos días para tomar
material y además desde que empezó la
pandemia como no se puede compartir el
material y no compartirlo así que deje
de tomar un poco mate durante la
pandemia ahora volveré porque me cuesta
tomar solo me gusta para mí el mate es
una actividad grupal habrá que tomar
vino francés entonces bueno no hay
problema me encanta también me encanta
eso también se puede compartir cada uno
con su vaso está bueno muchas gracias
jorge realmente por habernos recibido
haber tomado el tiempo de responder a
todas nuestras preguntas y ansias muchas
veces muchas gracias
quiero que
para cuándo
me haces ah